with kovid from day one he was always
trying to look at the data you know and
so by the time i started working it was
a little over a year ago it was spring
2021 before delta surge started and
delta it was bad i mean it was bad in
florida and everywhere in the country
and a lot of people had cobit and were
very sick
um and during that time you know
governor destanis i would see him almost
every day and he would be reading the
studies he'd be reading the latest
information from israel from europe from
countries that were ahead of us in the
delta search and he saw that number one
the vaccine is not stopping transmission
of the virus so the mandates made no
sense at all and he doubled out like no
matter what every single press
conference and we had press conferences
every day during that time we would get
reporters yelling in his face about when
are you going to do a lockdown what are
you going to do a mask mandate what
about vaccine minutes and he'll always
just say no i mean despite all of this
pressure because he knew what the data
said
and speaking of our governor
i am now going to bring out oh that
could be the gov calling into the show
right now
i am now going to bring out governor
desantis press secretary christina
bouchard i am not deterred
by
any smear piece from these legacy media
outlets
the only reason they're attacking her is
because she does a great job and she's
very effective at calling out their lies
and their phony narratives and so
whenever they're smearing somebody you
know that person is over the target so
they're scared of that i would be much
more concerned with my press secretary
if the washington post was writing puff
pieces about her then i would think
man how good is that now make some noise
for christina boucha
all right christina so why don't we just
clarify it in case anyone from media
matters is here
are you
an agent of another government or
foreign entity sent to florida to take
us out from the inside
absolutely
oh oh they shut her mic they shut her
mic
that was
yeah right no that was media matters
doing that they don't want me here
tonight i guess but no no i'm not an
agent of any foreign government i don't
know how i would have been hired by the
state of florida we had background
checks you know like to get hired right
and this thing that they were accusing
you of you actually had on your resume
that you've worked for some other people
in other countries absolutely i think
the fact that i worked in like a former
soviet country and in eastern europe
that's actually what helped me get this
job because i know
what communism does and what it is and
that's what we're fighting against here
right
[Applause]
so
so for the people that don't know you
too well or only know you through
twitter can you tell people a little bit
of your story because it's actually a
perfect
story for someone to come here to
florida to defend freedom to defend the
governor to defend all these people and
all that stuff yeah sure so i don't know
how much detail you want me to go into
but like you i'm from los angeles i grew
up in california so the people's
republic of california back when i was a
kid it wasn't as bad but with gavin
newsom i mean i know you guys saw some
of his latest hits it's gotten really
really bad
but when i was in college i studied
international relations i was always
really into foreign policy
and um international economics too so i
ended up long story short working in
eastern europe i worked in the country
of georgia
i studied abroad in russia and i learned
a lot about you know that part of the
world um and
basically the legacy of communism and
just how bad it was and how the effects
are still being felt today even though
these countries are not
communist anymore you know it's not
something you recover from very quickly
so
after seeing
how california such a beautiful state
was destroyed by one party ruled by
progressive democrats long story short
that's how i became a conservative now
how i came to florida is a little bit of
a different story it was during covid i
was living in washington d.c
i was working as a political consultant
so i worked on campaigns in other
countries
but during covett and dc i mean it was
miserable it was the entire city's
lockdown people in my neighborhood are
wearing masks outside i was running
outside one day i got yelled at for not
wearing a mask while i was on a run um
that was probably the moment i realized
i have to leave and this was also the
worst part was it wasn't just the
mandates that were making people like
act like this it was that they genuinely
in their hearts
they wanted to comply they wanted to
conform like that's the mentality of
progressives these days unfortunately
leftism and communism it's a very
conformist mentality and i just got
depressed like looking at this all
around me dc you know it's like 95 voted
for biden and i just felt like i'm in
the wrong place after the election of
last of 2020 um
and just a lot of stuff that happened
after that i realized this is the wrong
place for me florida was like the bright
light in the darkness it was like the
west berlin
of the cold war right like this is where
freedom still lives and so i'm like okay
i have to come to florida i love what
governor desantis is doing he is really
standing up against the whole like
biomedical security state the mandates
the restrictions the lockdowns
life is normal in florida and so i went
um for cpac 2021
met some people who worked with governor
desantis and spoke with them got to know
them
and long story short that's how i ended
up coming to florida and getting this
great job so very blessed to be here
it's really remarkable how florida man
the caricature of florida man you know
this guy with a cigar in one hand and
he's wrestling an alligator and ripping
a baby out of its head on a golf course
and it's like florida man knew something
right florida man was doing it right i
really for all you that are born and
bred floridians holy cow you really you
saved us you really did so so i know
people always want to know insider
things about the governor and you can't
share anything that's that's not to be
fully shared but when you got here you
start working for him now kovit's going
crazy it was not easy for him to to get
out there and say hey no i'm not going
to close the state i'm going to let
people go to work i'm not going to
inject everybody all that stuff can you
talk a little bit about his thought
process and how how he made decisions
well the first thing to understand about
governor desantis is that even though
he's not a doctor or a scientist by
training he's a smart guy and he likes
to read in detail before like he makes a
policy decision so with kovid from day
one he was always trying to look at the
data you know and so by the time i
started working it was a little over a
year ago it was spring 2021 before delta
surge started and delta it was bad i
mean it was bad in florida and
everywhere in the country and a lot of
people had cobit and were very sick
and during that time you know governor
destanis i would see him almost every
day and he would be reading the studies
he'd be reading the latest information
from israel from europe from countries
that were ahead of us in the delta surge
and he saw that number one the vaccine
is not stopping transmission of the
virus so the mandates made no sense at
all and he doubled out like no matter
what every single press conference and
we had press conferences every day
during that time we would get reporters
yelling in his face about when are you
going to do a lockdown when are you
going to do a mask mandate what about
vaccine minutes and he'll always just
say no i mean despite all of this
pressure because he knew what the data
said and so that's very different from a
lot of politicians they would look at
more like what the political data says
so like the polling data and the focus
groups and whatnot but he's not that
kind of a politician he is a leader that
means he looks at reality and makes a
decision based on that and then people
come along with him right and so
like
with mass mandates even
he knew
that even with delta
as bad as it was it thank god it wasn't
affecting children severely so
he thought it's more important i mean
he's a dad he has little kids he knows
how important it is for kids to like
have a normal life and go to school and
be with their friends and be in their
routines right and so that was one of
the things that was non-negotiable for
him like schools are going to be open
and kids are not going to be forced to
wear a mask the parents can make the
choice but kids are not going to be
forced and so
he was attacked non-stop for that and i
you know i heard him talking to people
like whether it was in private or in
public at a press conference and he was
always saying like look at the data kids
are okay it's going to be worse for kids
to be living in like this dystopia and
growing up without seeing faces and this
and that so like
now he's right now nobody wants to
remember like that they criticized him
for this now everyone pretends they were
on board with him the whole time with
schools being open with you know no mass
mandates and you know they're trying to
memory hole it but we remember how many
people attacked him
we remember
that he was really the first
politician to come out and say like
enough you know it's going to be up to
the parents and now everyone has
followed and that's great we're very
happy about that but like somebody had
to stand up and take the heat and at
that time
there were polls coming out last summer
saying that most parents wanted mass
mandates and he said okay that's because
they they're afraid they're being sold
lies by the media and they're being
basically manipulated into thinking this
and lo and behold he was right he had to
just make a decision that was unpopular
at the time and now everyone realizes
like he was right that's what leadership
is i think
don't you guys sort of feel like he
actually is the president in a way right
like in a way if america is going to
continue he sort of he's he may exactly
make america florida i think you mean
yeah
make america florida exactly
uh were there ever any moments in the
heat of all of it that he almost cracked
and gave in because everybody was coming
after him all the time i mean even now
still they're trying it i think when
people come after him it makes him even
more resolute in what he's doing the
more that the media attacks you saw the
clip that you rent right before like we
started talking the clip about me when i
got attacked he said you know that's
great when dr lotapo you know our great
surgeon general
thank you
he's awesome he gets attacked by the
media all the time i remember i was with
the surgeon general and the governor we
were at a wawa somewhere in the middle
of florida in tampa bay and i remember
in the tampa bay times the front page
was a story about dr lotapo and how he's
an anti-vaxxer quack and all of this
nonsense and so
it was when he was new he wasn't
confirmed yet as a surgeon general like
senate still had to do the confirmation
so i was a little bit concerned i look
at the paper i'm like dr lauda like are
you feeling okay you know he just came
from california he's not a politician
being in the public eye is kind of new
to him so i was like are you feeling
great and he's like yeah as long as the
governor is okay and the governor said
look
the more that people are attacking joe
that's what he calls doctor ladoff the
more people are attacking joe the better
because that means he's doing something
right
so speaking of doing something right i
think most of us can agree we're kind of
doing it right here in florida and
people are living free and all that
stuff is there anything that in florida
right now we're not doing right or
places that the governor or the
administration is going oh we have to
fix this or that
that's it
that's a
great question
honestly you didn't think i was going to
make it easy for you up here we can
always be doing better i think i mean
i'm really proud of what florida has
done of the example that we are to the
country um we are
a leader in school choice could always
do more on that um and i believe that'll
happen um
you know there's
a lot of conservatives come to me and
say like
constitutional carry is a big priority
for them and that's something the
governor has said that he is committed
to doing before um before he leaves
office so i believe i i've never heard
him say something that he doesn't follow
through on so
you know there are always ways we could
improve um and we're always trying to
listen to people listen to floridians
and look at what's going on in other
states other countries that we might be
able to use and we might be able to
replicate here but i do think florida
has been a good example for the country
so what else yeah you can apply that far
has been a pretty good example
what else do you think that that these
folks can do to help governor desantis
fight this thing to to get involved like
how can people you know beyond voting we
get it they get they're all going to get
out in november and vote and he's going
to win something like 90 percent of the
vote there you heard it first
but yeah what else what else can people
do do you think yeah you know but that
what you said is really important
because like i go to a lot of um
places in florida with the governor i
think he's been to all 67 counties this
year and i go to a lot of those places
and people will come up and say like how
great he is and how like they're going
to vote for him for president now i
always say wait wait back up he's not
running for president he's running for
reelection as the governor of the great
state of florida so you need to vote in
november like of this year so that's
what i'm always trying to remind people
she almost broke some serious news here
tonight that was like almost we don't
want to take anything for granted
because like you said 90 to vote i mean
that'll be great i think he deserves it
he deserves 100 but
florida it's it's always been a swing
state i believe it's becoming more of a
red state thanks to governor desantis
leadership
um
but we never take anything for granted
you know you have to always run like
you're 10 points behind and that's what
he's doing he's working hard um and
that's why i'm vote is my number one
thing talk to your friends family about
it you know don't take it for granted
that he's gonna win just because his
opponents are very weak which is true
but like you can't take anything for it
you never know what's gonna happen so so
i think that's um probably the main
thing and then get involved at the local
level like there are
these days i think
conservatives are realizing how
important school boards are it was never
that big of a thing until the last
couple of years i think parents have
realized like how much power they have
over your family's life over your kids
lives and how much they've abused their
power in some places including um here
in florida yeah unfortunately that
was one that did and there were
others as well and so i think that's
something that we can learn from and
that i know a lot of great conservatives
are running for school board including
in broward and everywhere in florida
actually this fall so we need to replace
the ones that acted like petty dictators
right and so getting involved locally is
important
well i'm going to bring out our other
two guests in a moment who are also
great floridians but i just want to say
since we got a room full of people here
that you guys are just doing an
incredible job and you helped me
make the move here and live a better
life here and all that stuff so make
some noise for christina everybody
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell